on va commencer oui c'est bon très bien
alors bonjour à tous à toutes et à tous
airs de vous retrouver pour cette
audition qui prend une forme un peu
différente des ateliers habituels de
l'université 133 puisque nous avons
organisé récemment un atelier société
solidarité sur les questions de
génération d'un phénomène entre les
générations et que nous avions prévu
donc même la députée nathalie avis et
limaces député du val d'oise nom de la
commission des affaires sociales vient
de réaliser avec vous une audition plus
individuel puisque aussi en raison de la
sortie prochaine de ce rapport nous
puissions engager la discussion de
manière peu à huit clos en quelque sorte
donc nous vous remercions d'être avec
nous et et on est très heureux de vous
additionnez avec donc je suis triste en
vélo je suis un des le co-rapporteur de
l'univers 633 est maître de conférences
en histoire contemporaine à l'université
catholique de lille et dans notre équipe
aujourd'hui nous retrouvons raphaël
liogier qui profite sur des universités
a lieu paix d'aix-en-provence et
professeur invité à la columbia
university ainsi que charles mercier
maître de conférences en histoire
contemporaine à l'université bordeaux et
donc charles qui est comme d'ailleurs
raphaël suivent plusieurs ateliers en
même temps charles et co rapporteur de
l'atelier solidarité citoyenneté laïcité
démocratie et appelle et rapporteur de
cet atelier six sociétés solidarité
c'est donc lui qui sera le rapporteur de
notre audition que nous allons entamer
une fois et c'est un peu la coutume en
quelque sorte de nos rencontres
une introduction historique très brève
mais en fait un exercice de généalogie
politique on prend le thème du jour et
on montre comment les centristes se sont
positionnés depuis les débuts de la
république c'est à dire depuis la
troisième
sur la question pour voir un petit peu
si nous sommes dans la continuité si
nous sommes un peu à l'écart voilà pour
resituer tout ça et après je vous
donnerai la parole donc pour vous nous
présentiez ce rapport à celle
d'apprendre à juste après 4h du
rapporteur et nous vous poserons les
questions nous avons une heure
d'audition puisque nous devons respecter
aussi le temps entendu qu'il ya des
réunions diverses et variées qui vont
suivre
et encore une fois donc merci bien pour
pour cela alors je dirais pour commencer
et pour être deux assez assez assez
synthétique que le centrisme les
centristes en général surtout sur la
question dite sociale ont été autant
nombre que sur le fond particulièrement
bien représentés dans nos républiques 3e
4e et 5e
nous avions avant tire un atelier sur
l'économie lit où je ne pouvais pas en
dire autant
parce que ils ont eu ce sont une
spécificité qui les portent qui n'est
pas la question sociale
lorsqu'on évoque la question de la
famille puisque c'est là dessus que je
vais m'exprimer
elle est je dirais encore plus près de
nantes
parce que commençons par la troisième
république
que ce soit sur la question de la
filiation que ce soit sur la question
des allocations familiales on en a déjà
parlé dans d'autres ateliers mais qui
naissent à ce moment là dans les années
que ce soit sur les politiques que
largement familial on trouve non
seulement les centristes dans les parmi
les législateurs mais on les trouve
comme menant la discussion c'est ça
c'est très important puisque tout ça
aboutit à la fin des années 30 avec la
création du ministère de la famille qui
est un ministère un des derniers nés de
la troisième république et qui est porté
dans la législation parlementaire
d'abord comme un projet des
parlementaires centristes c'est ce n'est
pas un ministre centriste premier
titulaire du ministère
mais c'est les centristes qui sont
largement leurs jours sous la quatrième
république bien sûr c'est à la suite de
ce que le programme du conseil national
de la résistance avec élaboré la
création de la sécurité sociale
et avec cela ne l'oublions pas la
continuité des politiques d'allocations
familiales déjà commencé sous la iiième
et là aussi on le retourne les retrouve
encore une fois de temps en
que dans leur singularité sur ces
politiques mises en place et madame la
députée vous qui avez été enseignante je
dois dire aussi que dans le cadre des
politiques scolaires de la quatrième
république nous avons un large volet lié
aux politiques familiales que je
rappellerai rapidement et enfin
cinquième république
là aussi si nous regardons tout
simplement les différents la formation
des différents gouvernements que nous
avons et les lois qui ont été votées on
s'aperçoit très vite aussi qu'ils sont
très présents sur cette question tant
d'ailleurs l'évolution de la famille a
été importante sous la vème république
juste jusqu'aux questions brûlantes si
je puis dire du mariage le mariage pour
tous et de l'affiliation sur tout et
puis dernièrement puisqu'il ya eu un
vote important à l'assemblée nationale
ces mois dernier sur les questions de
bioéthique
alors voilà mon plan trois parties mais
rappellera rassurez-vous strass à très
rapide et c'est simplement pour que ça
puisse être clairement clairement
indiquée sous la troisième république je
disais que quelques elles sont les
questions
la question sociale d'abord elle est née
une fille complètement une fois que la
question laïque a été traitée on fait
voter la loi de 1905 sur la séparation
de l'église et de l'état et le verrou
laïque en quelque sorte saute on peut
mettre à l'ordre du jour la question
sociale non pas qu'elle n'ait pas été
mise à l'ordre du jour plus tôt il ya eu
quelques lois sociales notamment la
reconnaissance des syndicats
professionnels par exemple et en plus
que cela mais surtout en quantité si je
puis dire la question sociale elle est
traitée après 1905 et sait c'est qu'elle
est elle vraiment la question familiale
c'est d'abord l'autorité paternelle sur
laquelle se retrouvent les ce qu'on
appelle les premiers démocrate-chrétien
le parti n'existe pas vraiment encore il
existera qu'en 1924 l'autorité
paternelle qui est en quelque sorte une
proposition de loi votée et adoptée est
promue par un député qui s'appelait
l'abbé lemire député du nord un député
en soutane démocrate chrétien qui fait
voter la loi sur cette autorité pas
ne sera pas le seul mais c'est de la
première et puis il y à toute une série
de textes notamment de proposition de
loi sur la politique des allocations de
famille comme on les appelle à l'époque
aide aux familles nombreuses ou on voit
poindre le rôle des parents dans
l'éducation
jusqu à l'oral jusqu'à la rédaction des
manuels scolaires
la famille est au coeur des politiques
sociales ça c'est très important pour
les républicains de l'époque puisqu'on
vient de construire l'école républicaine
et on doit poursuivre cela dans la
politique familiale il ya la question de
la protection de la moralité de
l'enfance de sa santé et là nous avons
toute une série de lois qui je rentre
pas dans le détail mais qui permettent
d'illustrer ce propos
et puis un souci constant croissant qui
n'est pas partagé par tous au départ
mais qui va l'être de plus en plus et
surtout après la première guerre
mondiale
le souci des républicains pour les
familles nombreuses les familles
nombreuses
si bien que à la suite de la création de
ce qu'on appelle l'alliance nationale
pour l'accroissement de la population
française qui est une quine à la fin du
19e siècle
on a et pas seulement dans les milieux
catholiques rallier la république mais
dont parmi les républicains même un acre
est véritablement forte pour la question
des allocations familiales et à une
première loi en 1910 qui est porté par
les centristes s'appelle la loi landry
honorât andré honnorat qui est un
centriste plutôt de centre gauche on va
dire et qui font de cette politique là
il y à une succession de politique de
deux lois votées sur les familles
nombreuses qui aboutissent à la
législation bonnevay qui feint centriste
du nord et à la fin des années vingt par
la loi loucheur 1928 quand un autre
centriste du nord on a parlé d'ailleurs
de nos chauffeurs pour d'autres
questions récemment notamment les
questions liées à l'eau logement et aux
constructions de cette âme aux
habitations à bon marché
il ya donc presque une série
d'initiatives législatives qui viennent
du camp centriste sur ces questions là
jusqu'aux congés de maternité et à
l'assistance aux familles nombreuses
nécessiteuses qui complète en quelque
sorte le le le
l'appareil législatif le consensus est
obtenue dans l'entre-deux-guerres j'en
finis avec la troisième république sur
cette question là en effet on se rallie
à la politique
des familles nombreuses et des
allocations familiales puisque c'est
bien dans l'entre-deux guerres que se
concrétise cette législation sur la
famille sur les allocations familiales
la grande loi c'est la loi du 11 mars
1932 qui généralise les allocations
familiales qui prolonge la loi loucheur
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure et qui a
abouti à un code de la famille fin des
années 30 qui est extrêmement important
pour ce qui se passera après notamment
en 45 soit avec la sécurité sociale
finalement on a donc une progression je
pourrais la préciser davantage mais des
centristes bien dans ce domaine là alors
je précise qu'ils ne sont pas les seuls
je disais que le premier titulaire du
ministère de la famille qui est monsieur
pernaut n'est pas un centriste patentés
qui n'en est pas loin mais qui n'est pas
inscrit dans le groupe mais les
parlementaires car c'est eux qui font la
loi ne l'oublions jamais sont
d'inspiration largement centristes
autour de ce phénomène alors deuxième
temps c'est ce qui se passe après après
l'oeuvre donc du gouvernement provisoire
de la pub française avec la quatrième
république
on a là ce qu'on appelle une démocratie
apaisée de la famille il n'ya plus les
grands débats sur ce qu'il faut défendre
la famille nombreuse pas la défendons à
atteindre le rythme de croisière et ce
sont encore une fois des parlementaires
plutôt modérée à qui on donne
systématiquement les portefeuilles
ministériels en lien avec la famille
nous allons retrouver là des grands ça
sent triste la plupart du temps des
démocrates chrétiens qu'on a retrouvé
aussi au travail ou à la reconstruction
je pense notamment à quelqu'un qui a eu
le ministère pendant longtemps c'est
encore au vu de l'instabilité
ministérielle ce n'était pas facile
notamment quelqu'un qui s'appelait paul
bacot députés et même des ministres à
merpins du mouvement républicain
populaire qui est celui qui va le plus
agir pour la progression la
structuration des politiques de famille
nombreuse
alors je n'emprunte pas davantage parce
qu'on pourra peut-être à paris dans le
débat mais il faut bien voir que ils
sont présents là cette fois ci peut être
plus visibles au gouvernement qu'ils ne
l'étaient plus tôt avant au parlement
mais qu'il s'attache à construire une
politique publique des politiques
publiques très favorable c'est là que je
veut adjoindre aux propos la question
scolaire parce que on sait tous que sous
la ivème
la querelle entre l'école privée l'école
l'école publique et que nous avons des
ministres centristes qui sont ici ou là
aussi de la démocratie chrétienne et qui
y vont en quelque sorte un peu pousser
davantage de l'école privée même si
c'est jamais au désavantage de l'école
publique puisque c'est un alignement du
privé sur le public
et là je pense notamment à germaine
poinsot chapuis député de marseille
ministre de la santé qui avec son fameux
décret va permettre par l'octroi à des
femmes à toutes les familles de france
qu'elle choisisse le public ou le privé
de bourses pour scolariser leurs enfants
alors bien sûr indique cnn ou privés
mais c'est en quelque sorte un
rééquilibrage
je pense également aux lois marie
baranger qui vont dans le même sens
qu'ils sont issus aussi de tradition
centriste par les deux personnalités
monsieur mari monsieur baranger qu'il
est en sont les auteurs je pense enfin à
un grand parlementaires centristes
qu'ils amendent et précis de cette
législation qui est monsieur simonet et
qui l'année d'après en 50 2950 2 peut
pas refaire un système qui marche plutôt
plutôt bien on sait quand même que la
chorale scolaire continue elle sera en
partie réglée par la loi debré de 59 et
j'en arrive au 3e et dernier temps c'est
la cinquième république
est ce que les centristes on les
retrouve encore dans un régime fondé par
le gaullisme présent dans ses politiques
sociales
est-ce qu'ils sont aussi singulier qu'il
il était précédemment puisqu'ils ont
introduit quand même et ont réussi à
introduire la politique des familles
nombreuses
oui oui au début en tout cas et après
avec l'évolution de la question il ya
plus de tension on va dire que ce grand
public précédente
d'abord paul bacot sous la ivème
continue sous la vème c'est une rareté
absolue dans la constitution qu'il ya
une telle continuité ministériel à un
poste alors qu on change de république
paul bacot est à nouveau ministre et on
a là de quelques grands noms je pense
qu'il faut citer on l'a pas cité
suffisamment encore mais joseph fontanet
qui a été secrétaire général du mrp qui
a porté tout simplement le centriste le
centrisme le français de l'a4 de la fin
de la 4e et début de la cinquième et qui
oppose de mise la santé puis plus tard
du travail et de l'éducation
élargira considérablement le socle
centriste sur ces questions de famille
alors comment les centristes en quelques
mots font ils face à l'évolution dans
les changements structurels de la
famille qui sont très forts finalement
on sait le rôle de ces centrée sur les
question très délicate je pense à deux
personnalités en particulier je pense à
deux sujets à un sujet en particulier
même si on pouvoir parler également de
la contraception je parle à lille et
j'ai je pense talibés jet li léger et
qu'on a voté en 74 loi de 75 simone veil
issu d'un centrisme d'inspiration
libérale mais d'un centrisme quand même
et l'auteur de ces lois donc
d'accompagnement des questions
familiales nez mais elle est précédée
dans la discussion parlementaire par une
personnalité qui est encore si je puis
dire encore plus centristes qu'elle
puisque pas d'inspiration libérale mais
d'inspiration démocrate chrétienne sans
appartenir au parti démocrate chrétien
mais aux grands partis centristes
république parlementaire on appeler le
le le vous qui porte un nom je ne
donnerai pas tout de suite ici parce que
c'est pas l'objet mais qui et qui
permettait d'enjamber les deux centres
bon c'était lui dsr l'union l'union
démocratique et socialiste de la
résistance et on avait donc des
parlementaires de centre gauche comme de
centre-droit cette personnalité c'était
que du scotti qui a beaucoup oeuvré en
matière de logement qui a beaucoup
oeuvré matière d'architecturé de
reconstruction n'a parlé dans ses
ateliers et qui est celui qui va
convaincre les derniers
démocrate-chrétien résistants qu'il faut
voter les dg il ouvrir en quelque sorte
tous les le gauche de la majorité de
droite si je puis dire ça comme ça au
vote favorable à simone veil qui doit
recueillir à l'eau si comme on le sait
une large partie des votes favorables à
la gauche et qui n'obtiendra pas tous
les votes favorables à la droite et donc
ça c'est important pour repositionner
les centristes in alors le centrisme
reste identique man située sur le
financement de la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale tass et son grand
domaine de bacon jusqu'à jacques barrot
on aura là des gens qui garderont en
quelque sorte
lorsqu'ils seront munis du travail
notamment jacques barrot et des affaires
sociales
grand rôle dans la conservation et la
vigilance vis-à-vis de la branche
famille mais il ya également la
politique de sélectivité des politiques
familiales ou là ce sera plus difficile
et plus délicat
en tout cas dans la discussion on voit
bien poindre un sentiment très très très
il faut faire beaucoup discernement et
il y aura quelques conflits quelques
divisions mais globalement avec ce que
je vienne dans le droit fil de ce que je
viens de dire une forme de fidélité aux
principes anciens et déjà développé
alors c'est le cas notamment sur la
filiation et à la suite notamment du
rapport terry qui a été déposée en 2014
mais il y avait déjà quelques échos
négociations plutôt tous les centristes
ne sont pas sur la même longueur d'onde
mais se retrouve sur la conservation
d'un modèle familial adapté à la société
de nos jours là où il ya une continuité
peut-être plus forte c'est sur la
bioéthique
même si c'est à la marge la question
familiale qu'on évoque en ce moment la
bioéthique quittera la très à la marge
mais elle est beaucoup liés sur certains
aspects en tout cas de la bioéthique à
la famille et là on a fait quelques
études pour montrer quand même que les
centristes en général s'abstiennent sur
les lois bioéthiques il y à des
centristes qu'ils votent pour
il y en a eu d'ailleurs au groupe du
mouvement démocrate récemment il y en a
qui votent contre y en a eu un
un parlementaire aussi mais la majorité
du groupe s'abstient parce que là encore
c'est une tradition que de participer au
débat d'amendé mais ne pas forcément
voté en faveur des lois même c'est
peut-être qu'une avancée par ailleurs
c'est toujours un point d'interrogation
aussi pour eux voilà alors pour terminer
complètement je dirais que s'il ya bien
un domaine d'enfin matière de famille
sous la vème république dans lequel les
centristes ont été très très très
vigilant c'est la sécurité sociale je
les ai déjà dit sur la branche famille
mais c'est c'est un domaine en tout cas
au plan parlementaire où ils sont
omniprésents je renvoie tous les débats
sur la haye aux archives de la
commission des affaires sociales a vendu
à l'époque des affaires culturelles
familiales et sociales de l'assemblée
devenue un terreau social
qui sont véritablement passionnante et
je pense surtout fait souvent référence
à lui à jacques barrot parce qu'il a été
le ministre peut-être le plus actif en
la matière en 95 et des mines du travail
et des affaires sociales il travaille
beaucoup avec une ministre dont on vient
de créer le ministère et qui peut-être
correspond à la titulature le plus à
notre objet du jour ministère des rois
des la générosité entre les générations
et ça c'était une parlementaire lilloise
à l'époque gaulliste ou colette
codaccioni qui avait eu le poste jacques
barrot et émis des affaires sociales et
ils avaient beaucoup travaillé ensemble
donc voila un petit peu la continuité
historique de nos centriste sur les
questions liées à la famille j'ai voulu
être extrêmement rapide et synthétique
j'espère que j'ai pas été non plus trop
long je vous remercie
je vous remercie de votre attention et
donc nous pouvons
madame la députée engagé audition avec
les représentations de votre futur
rapport merci merci à vous et surtout
portant ses informations et ses
éclairages très utile en effet c'est
important pour recadrer les choses et en
vous écoutant emilia ma foi je suis
conforté dans l'idée d'être vraiment
dans la tradition centriste
même si évidemment ce rapport répond en
tout cas temps de répondre à des enjeux
qui sont vraiment ceux de notre époque
où la façon de faire famille bien sûr a
considérablement évolué fmi ait les
hétérosexuels et homosexuels et les
compose et décompose et enfin voilà donc
elle et elle est très mouvante et autres
en tout cas elle a elle a beaucoup
évolué et c'est d'ailleurs alors juste
pour rappeler quand même l'histoire de
ce rapport il a été décidé l'année
dernière de créer cette mission
d'information donc autour de la
politique familiale et surtout comment
l'adapter aux grands enjeux de notre
époque
après
le discours de politique générale du
premier ministre le 12 juin dernier
donc on est en 2019 et le premier
ministre vient à l'assemblée nationale
fait un discours de politique générale
et on parle de famille mais on en parle
de façon assez dissocier on parle de la
famille monoparentale on parle par
exemple des aidants familiaux
on met aussi un petit peu le handicap en
voilà mais je ne vois pas d'ambition
globale en fait
j'entends parler de famille un peu à
droite à gauche
et d'ailleurs c'est un peu la tendance
est en tout cas c'est ce que je déplore
c'est que dès lors que on va mettre en
place un dispositif autour de la garde
d'enfants par exemple on nous dit que
voilà c'est de la politique familiale et
bien moi je ne crois pas que ce soit ça
c'est trop saucissonnée si je puis dire
et donc en concertation avec donc aux
démocrates et apparentés et son
président patrick mignola nous avons mis
en place cette mission d'information
dans le cadre de notre droit de tirage
pour vraiment porter des propositions en
vue de restaurer ou de rétablir une
politique familiale forte et ambitieuse
voilà un petit peu le le contexte est ce
pour quoi je suis rapporteur de cette
mission
ensuite dans l'organisation des trains
vous avez beaucoup parlé de filiation et
de bioéthique
nous avons installé la mission l'année
dernière l'été dernier est effectivement
dès septembre il ya nous avions l'examen
du texte de bioéthique à l'assemblée et
nous avons pas mal auditionné en ce sens
autour de la filiation de l'écriture de
ceux de la réécriture de ce titre 7 du
code civil de son cadre juridique
éventuellement des écueils des
inquiétudes des angoisses que nous
pouvions avoir les uns et les autres
notamment quant à la gpa très
précisément voilà donc nous avons
d'abord commencé à travailler sur cette
question là alors c'est vrai que
certains s'en sont étonnés
considérant qu une mission sur la
politique familiale devait traiter
essentiellement de deux grands piliers
si je puis dire un volet peut-être sur
la politique sur le pardon la spec taux
fiscal budgétaire et un autre qui a l'a
plutôt dans le sens de la conciliation
entre la vie familiale et la vie
professionnelle et moi il me semblait
justement au contraire important
d'introduire cette notion dans ce cas
dans le rapport qui est celle de la
filiation parce que bah il est aussi
question de natalité quand on parle de
politique familiale et donc j'ai pensé
que ça ferait sens de travailler sur ces
questions et aussi d'interroger
notamment la fertilité
voilà donc nous avons commencé par cela
et puis ensuite nous avons progressé et
comme nous entrions derrière dans
l'examen du plf et plfss
alors nous avons commencé à travailler
et à auditionner vraiment au fond sur
les questions de doughty fiscaux et
notamment interrogé le retour aux deux
rabot successifs que l'on a connues du
quotient familial temps sous le
quinquennat hollande que sur le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy de
réinterroger aussi notamment
universalité alors universalité encore
une fois il faut être très précis sur
les termes quand on parle d'universalité
de réinterroger d'universalité
c'est surtout réinterroger la condition
de ressources ou pas pour verser ces
allocations familiales voilà donc nous
avons travaillé donc je vous le présente
largement comme ça qu'après je vous
propose de m'interroger ce sera plus
simple
nous avons donc évoluer en ce sens donc
en nous interrogeant sur l'île
universalité sur le quotient familial
en regardant
l'impact que cela a eu notamment que le
cc 2 rabot successifs en termes de
pouvoir d'achat tout simplement des
familles et quelles sont les familles
qui sont véritablement concernés par ces
rabbo et puis j'ai beaucoup insisté
aussi sur cette partie du rapport sur un
écueil qui s'est mis en place je pense
progressivement alors je vous ai dit et
laure composent une mesure en lien de
près ou de loin à la famille on dit
qu'on fait de la politique familiale
il y a quelque chose que l'on confond
malheureusement chez nous c'est la
politique sociale et la politique
familiale
donc voila j'aimerais vraiment que l'on
puisse rétablir l'équilibré entre les
deux se sont l'objet des premières
réflexions que nous avons eues à cette
période
et puis ensuite nous avons progressé et
nous avons travaillé la plus sûre la
conciliation de la vie familiale et de
la vie professionnelle en ayant aussi à
l'esprit quelque chose qui est
d'ailleurs dans les dents dans les
objectifs en tout cas eu dans les
priorités du président de la république
c'est égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes est donc là il semblait vraiment
pertinent de porter un regard précis et
d'apporter des propositions sur les
modes de garde par exemple sur le congé
parental etc
donc voila un petit peu les grandes
lignes de notre réflexion au départ et
puis comme tout le monde le sait la
crise sanitaire est passée par là et
nous avons été confrontés à de nouvelles
questions
nous voyons de plus en plus de familles
dans la précarité
nous avons eu aussi à nous confronter
par obligation au télétravail et donc
j'ai voulu aussi qu'on regarde de ce
côté là ce que nous pourrions avoir à
faire et comment la politique familiale
pour lui aussi percuté ces sujets là
nous avons également réinterroger le
logement nous avons été interrogés
la culture les loisirs bref cette partie
du rapport qui devait être presque
circonscrite à la conciliation entre la
vie familiale et la vie professionnelle
bien s'est trouvé un petit peu élargi
aussi du fait de l'actualité est donc
finalement on est plus juste sur la
conciliation entre ces deux pôles de nos
vies mais vraiment sur la volonté de
réfléchir à l'épanouissement dans la
famille voilà tous ces sujets le travail
être bien logés l'accès à la culture
l'accès aux loisirs
et donc voilà et encore une fois parce
que la crise est passée par là
nous avons réordonner un petit peu le le
plan de ce rapport donc donc qui démarre
donc avec la première partie sur les
aides financières qui sont portées aux
familles
moi j'ai un regard et un accueil assez
arrêté sur le retour à l'universalité ou
pas sur le quotient familial et sur des
mesures comme ça qui sont très
techniques et g et financière ensuite
nous avons un travail qui a été mené
donc autour du bien-être et de
l'épanouissement dans la famille
alors la famille vous avez monsieur
bellion beaucoup parlé de la famille
mais des familles nombreuses
alors ça a été le cas effectivement ce
sans doute dans la progression
je le comprends aujourd'hui mais on a
aussi un sujet un souci aujourd'hui qui
est la natalité dans ce pays où les
femmes ne sont plus en
de sa de deux enfants en état en-deça de
deux enfants par femme et donc il ya un
impact très directs sur les solidarités
est donc aujourd'hui nous le disait la
famille elle est très diverse et les
hétérosexuels et homosexuels et voilà
mais elle est aussi monoparentales voilà
et donc il faut le considérer et il faut
pouvoir aussi apporter des réponses à
ces familles monoparentales
voilà alors je voulais j'ai brossé le
sujet de façon assez large et une
dernière chose quand même qui est
importante
donc on a parlé des familles nombreuses
aujourd'hui on a aussi ce regard sur les
familles monoparentales et alors je ne
sais plus où mais je les noter en tout
cas dans le rapport
je souhaite que l'on ne regarde pas la
famille uniquement que sous le prisme de
l'enfance mais véritablement je souhaite
que l'on puisse considérer la famille à
tous les âges de la vie
c'est à dire depuis la petite enfance
jusqu'aux dépendance voilà ça a été très
fort notamment aussi cette question et
ce point là pendant la crise que nous
venons de traverser
on a une crise de confiance majeure dans
ce pays et je pense que la politique
familiale en tout cas ce projet cette
ambition tels que je vais essayer de la
delà de la développer aurait un intérêt
en tout cas c'est mon objectif c'est ce
que j'essaie de faire passer c'est
vraiment de restaurer aussi de la
cohésion sociale et la cohésion sociale
elle trouve son origine dans la famille
et si en plus on peut mettre autour les
outils permettant cet épanouissement
dans la famille je crois qu'on aurait
fait un groupe
y'a pas de micro micro paillettes
je vous entends merci madame est député
donc c'était très intéressant
alors vous avez en quelque sorte
raisonnée et c'est tout à fait logique
puisque nous sommes en train de faire la
loi sur aussi les les problématiques ult
très récente qui touche la famille tout
en considérant celle qu'ils ont concerné
directement dans le passé et en effet je
n'ai pas parlé mais pour la dépendance
est en tout cas pour ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le phénomène des cinq
générations
les centristes on devrait aussi au
parlement comme au ministère notamment
je pense à la prestation dépendance qui
avaient été installés à ce tour et en 81
15 ou 16
et puis qui a donné suite à la panne qui
elle a été instaurée juste après par
martine aubry
et donc ils ont été au fil de la 5ème
très très présents aussi je pense alors
il faudrait peut-être affiné dans une
étude historique mais le rôle qu'ils ont
eue sur la gestation en faveur de l'as
de la dépendance mais en tout cas ils
effectuent un travail et alors il ya une
dépendance à la qui arrive prochainement
à l'assemblée
mais j'ai moi même et je travaille
toujours aussi sur le sujet des aidants
familiaux
voilà qui est aussi à intégrer justement
de mont so lu ment alors je donne la
parole à raphaël liogier professeur à
l'épée d'aix-en-provence philosophe et
sociologue je n'ai pas dit tout à
l'heure et raphaël et rapporteur de
l'atelier vous avez la parole raphaël
merci christophe merci alors je veux
vous poser deux petites questions mais
avant je voudrais faire un certain
nombre de remarques je peux pas m'en
empêcher parce que je suis très bavard
bonjour je le dis si vous n'avez pas
vous avez pas vu jusque-là ce que c'est
vrai que je suis un petit peu bavard
mais donc ça ça comment dire ça wing
beurre comme disent les anglais
certaines de certaines de leurs marques
moi je crois que effectivement on doit
considérer la famille comme étant la
cellule famille la cellule sociale
fondamentale parce que c'est la cellule
de socialisation primaires comme disent
les sociologues mais c'est pas la
cellule de socialisation primaire et
vous l'avait bien dit
et vous avez raison je crois de dire ça
c'est pas la cellule de socialisation
primaires parce que ça se rapportent
essentiellement aux enfants c'est la
cellule de socialisation primaires tout
au long de la vie et ça continue à être
une cellule de socialisation prix mais
pas au sens temporel du terme mais au
sens où c'est d'abord là que ça se passe
et c'est effectivement le cas de la
cohésion sociale ça se passe mal dans la
famille ça se passe mal dans la société
si ça se passe mal dans j'allais dire
cette première molécule cette première
molécule sociale eh bien ça se passe
bien dans la société par une sorte
d'effet si je puis dire d'effet
d'entraînement et donc je dirais que et
là je voudrais parler de faire une
distinction parce que vous avez parlé
d'un côté de vous disiez vie familiale
vie professionnelle etc
en faisant cette distinction entre le
familial est ce qui serait plus le
social moi je crois que c'est pour une
fois cet exposé ce monde sociétal qui
est intéressant c'est à dire je crois
qu'il ya deux dimensions
il ya la dimension de la dimension du
social et la dimension du sociétal et un
certain nombre d'écueils dans lequel on
plonge aujourd'hui compris dans ce qui
compte en ce qui concerne les
allocations familiales la question des
parts fiscales des du quotient familial
etc
c'est de confondre et c'est ce qu'a fait
françois hollande à mon avis c'est ce
que je reprocherais c'est de confondre
le social avec le société le sociétal
c'est le rapport dans la définition d'un
delà de là on va dire de l'année delà de
la république française c'est plus ceux
qui regardent la liberté qu'est ce que
la liberté jusqu'où on peut aller
c'est-à-dire dans les modèles sociétaux
qui permettent à un individu d'être
libre mais en restant humain
l'humanisme des centristes et puis d'un
autre côté c'est le social c'est la
question de légalité de l'égalité en
termes d'égalité des chances surtout du
point de vue centriste et pas d'égalité
au sens de l'égalitarisme
socialo-communiste si je sais si je te
dire et donc je crois qu'il faut bien
distinguer ces deux aspects et ces deux
aspects sont dans les deux cas indexés
sur l'objectif du progrès qui
maintiennent malgré tout une certaine
comment dire une certaine forme de
tradition c'est toute la question aussi
du centre il ya les vrais à cet objectif
du progrès du point de vue de l'égalité
sociale il du progrès du point de vue
sociétal du point
la liberté c'est à dire des modèles
familiaux et je crois d'un côté on a
donc je répète social avec cette espèce
de d'arrière fond il et d'égalité et
donc là on peut réfléchir à la question
de la redistribution sociale de la
précarité de sexe certains de
l'exclusion etc etc
et puis ensuite pendant la question de
sociétal lorsqu'on parle de la famille
c'est à dire là les jusqu'où peut aller
la liberté en attendant la question de
la filiation e de l'uem l'anah delà de
la reproduction des comportements
sexuels divers et variés de l'image
tolérable ou pas tolérable de ce que
doit être la la famille mais même de
l'image de la femme et de l'image même
par exemple du mariage je crois qu'il
faut aller jusqu'au bout lui du mariage
comme convention spécifique énoncées par
le code civil convention basique qui
peut aboutir sur des contrats mais à
cette chose contrat et je pars du point
de vue purement juridique là le rapport
même en conventionnel est ce que on est
on est dans l'idée
complètement libéral d'un mariage qui
est fondée sur la liberté du
consentement non fondées sur le
consentement consentement ou alors
est-ce qu'on est dans le mariage comme
étant fondateur d'une dune d'une image
particulière qui serait naturel l'idée
d'un côté on a le consensus à l'isthme
et puis de notre côté on a le
naturalisme ça c'est que ça c'est une
vraie question parce que y compris quand
il ya eu la manif pour tous et toutes
ces choses assez là dessus c'est là
dessus qu'on c'est là dessus qu'on a
buté personnellement puisque je me situe
comme christofle c'est plutôt du côté
libéral au sens du xviiie siècle
moi je crois que le code civil pourrait
encore progresser j'avais choqué un
certain nombre de gens de journalistes
même à qui j'avais dit mais dans le code
civil
on a toujours pour toi je suis croyante
mais ça n'a rien à voir on a toujours
des traces spécifique d'une image
particulière de ce que doit être le
mariage ne serait ce de dire c'est un
homme une femme ou un homme une femme
si c'est une convention pourquoi est-ce
que ça serait pas trois hommes deux
femmes deux femmes ça n'a rien à voir
avec la police je sais ça avait choqué
immédiatement parce que c'est parce que
je fais abstraction je fais les poké sur
l'image particulière de ce que seraient
les sens de la famille un homme une
femme sur tout tout comment dire toutes
conditions des moeurs mais et à ce
moment là on peut dire mais finalement
la seule chose c est ce qu il y à un
consentement éclairé pour la
constitution d'un d'une cellule de vie
pour un certain nombre d'individus ont
aussi approché de sa en réalité parce
que vous avez dit vous même c'est plus
seulement l'hétérosexualité
c'est l'homosexualité c'est le seul mais
en réalité le prochain la prochaine
étape c'est ce que je suis en train de
dire même si ça vous choque aujourd'hui
il ya vingt ans ça nous aurait choqué
tout autant en tout cas tout le monde
aurait souri le fait que je dise la
famille c'est aussi ces deux hommes ou
alors de femmes ou ceux ci cela on voit
bien qu'ils aient encore de résistance
en fait il on voit bien qu'il ya encore
un pas qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
franchie donc jusqu'où peut-on aller de
ce point de vue là c'est pour ça que je
n'étais pas d'accord avec ce que vous
avez dit christophe sur une chose
vous l'avez dit façon très très près ce
que de façon questionneur de façon très
centriste ont pour éclairer vous avez
déplacé en questionnant c'est la
bioéthique la bioéthique elle fait pour
moi entièrement partie du de la question
maintenant si elle fait partie de la
question familiale la bioéthique est ce
que ça veut dire qu'elle doit être
l'objet d'une est-ce qu'elle doit être
l'objet de lois c'est à dire qu'elle
doit être légiférer et légiférer et là
je trouve ça très intéressant que
beaucoup de centristes n'ai pas voté
parce que si j'avais été député moi je
n'aurais pas voté non plus pas parce que
je considère pas que c'est fondamental
mais parce que je considère c'est que si
c'est éthique c'est pas l'objet d'une
loi il faut savoir on est quand même
dans la seule sa société au monde où on
comment dire où on légalise les tic
l'éthique c'est ce qui détermine si
c'est à dire c'est le débat c'est la
fera débat social dans l'espace public
qui permet de déterminer des valeurs qui
vont être ensuite peuvent être ensuite
faire l'objet d'une noix mais faire une
loi
éthique ça suppose qu'il y aurait des
lois qui ne sont pas éthiques
ce qui est quand même fascinant dans
notre société si on va jusqu'au bout de
neuf alors sur sur le le la la
problématique maintenant plus
particulière et dans ce que vous avez
dit j'aurais donc de question d'y
répondre pour moi quand même juste pour
finir un des enjeux de la politique
familiale c'est ne pas glisser en
politique des moeurs
c'est à dire en police des moeurs
comment est ce qu'on peut faire une
politique de 1915 une police des moeurs
je parle du point de vue sociétal c'est
pour ça que de ce point de vue là j'ai
une question est-ce que vous avez parlé
de la gpe affiliation etc
est ce que vous avez en tant que député
est ce que le groupe a une position
anthropologique parce que là c'est une
question anthropologique c'est une
question sur qu'est ce que l'homme
si on parle qu'est ce que la filiation
qu'est ce que devrait être la filiation
qu'est ce que devrait être l'homme
l'homme en société donc la famille
la gpa c'est quelque chose qui engage à
des positions anthropologique est ce
qu'il y a une position anthropologique
de fond avant de discuter des
conséquences de parler des effets parce
que c'est souvent une manière de masquer
ce que vraiment on a dans le coeur en
terme d'image delà de ce qu'on voit là
ça c'est ma première question est ma
deuxième question et la houille sans
cette première question je ne prends pas
position assez rare que je dise ne donne
pas mon avis parce que d'habitude je
peux pas m'en empêcher
et si on l'a sur la deuxième question
c'est la question justement ce que vous
avez évoqué qu fiscale sociale etc
l'idée de retour à l'universalité moi je
poserai la question clairement est ce
que vous êtes pour un retour à
l'universalité
en ce qui me concerne je suis pour un
retour à l'universalité puisque je
considère que depuis françois hollande
en particulier le fait d'avoir mis des
barèmes des plafonds et c'est pour les
allocations familiales
c'est une trahison de l'esprit de ce que
sont les allocations familiales du point
de vue sociétal
on profite d'un projet d'une projection
sociale dont ce n'est pas l'objet ça va
pas dire qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait de
la redistribution sociale mais ce n'est
pas l'objet c'est pas la redistribution
sociale c'est pas de l'égalisation
social c'est autre chose
le fait de parler de conditions de
ressources à ce niveau là aussi bien
pour les allocations familiales que
concernant le cossu le quotient familial
donc je vous poserai la question là par
curiosité dans la mesure où à ma
position c'est pour le retour au aaa
sortir de cette de cette confusion que
j'ai évoquée dès le début en dieu qu'on
devrait distinguer les deux voilà les
deux questions merci
sur la première question relative à la
gpa et plus globalement aux lois de
bioéthique alors très simplement ce qui
s'est passé dans notre groupe politique
si globalement par traditionnellement
j'allais dire évidemment en amont nous
discutons des textes nous avons parfois
des positions divergentes mais
comme nous sommes centriste c'est vrai
nous arrive souvent un consensus pour le
coup sur ce texte là il n'y avait pas de
consensus recherché nulle part il y
avait vraiment une liberté de vote
parce que ça vient percuter des
questions qui sont très intime ça voilà
chacun a son idée son opinion sur le
sujet son histoire personnelle aussi
je ne citerai personne mais il ya dans
notre groupe il est des élus qui ont
peut-être eu à faire justement à la pma
ou voilà donc c'était c'est extrêmement
personnel ça l'est resté
alors sur la question de la gpa on n'est
pas allé à l'occasion de nos réunions
tout cas de nos discussions aussi loin
puisque c'est un sujet qui est plutôt
venue percuter les débats en séance avec
différentes tentatives comme ça d'
intrusion et pour le coup alors si sur
le texte bioéthique effectivement
majoritairement nous sommes abstenus et
je me suis abstenu sur la question de la
pma j'ai une certaine ouverture d'esprit
en revanche elle est complètement
tranché médiatiquement autour de la gpa
est globalement je dirais que mes
collègues vont dans ce sens
mais pour pouvoir répondre très finement
et précisément à votre caisse où il
faudrait qu'on arrive à avoir ce débat
là et nous n'avons pas eu alors je vous
rassure c'est tout à fait possible
encore parce que le texte revient à
l'assemblée du 11 juillet pour la
dernière lecture nous serons à nouveau
en commission spéciale fin juin début
juillet et est à nouveau en séance pour
voter le texte puisque notamment sur la
pma c'était un engagement du candidat
macro il y avait les attentes en effet
est donc le calendrier celui ci et nous
reviendrons donc en séance en début de
mois une sur sur ce vote définitif
puisque nous avons terminé la la navette
sur la question de l'universalité
moi ma position l éclair est d'ailleurs
là pour le coup ça pourrait être
retransmis parce qu'elle est aussi
connue depuis le début de la législature
pardon je porte cet amendement au plfss
de restauration de l'universalité à son
origine voilà donc de ce point de vue là
je n'ai aucun aucun secret jeu et là
c'est nous puisque je le porte pour le
groupe
collectivement nous sommes favorables et
nous demandons un retour effectivement à
l'universalité et je partage vos propos
je crois qu'effectivement il ya eu là
une trahison de l'esprit de ce que c'est
véritablement de même que nous portons
jeu puisque je suis dans le groupe un
peu celle qui s'est emparée dès le
départ de ces questions là et donc je
porte ces questions pour le groupe
depuis le départ également sur le
quotient familial et donc de delà de la
restitution de ces deux rabot successifs
il faut quand même savoir que c'est très
précis 1
mais les familles qui sont concernées
donc ont perdu près de 700 euros de
pouvoir d'achat
voilà c'est pas non plus complètement
anodin aussi si on raisonne de façon
beaucoup plus pratique et pragmatique
est-ce que je me posais une question
complémentaire à celle de raphaël qui
parlait de positionnement
anthropologique justement puisque vous
porter le projet pour pour le groupe
est-ce que et en fonction des résultats
sur lesquels auquel vous avez abouti qui
n'ont pas été comment dirais-je issus de
toutes les discussions que vous auriez
pu évoquer vous venez de le dire
gpa est ce que vous diriez qu'il existe
à l'appui de ce texte est encore en
cours de discussion
une forme de singularité centriste de la
filiation est ce qu'on peut le dire
qu'ils disent qu'ils vous distinguerez
de la majorité dans son ensemble puisque
vous parliez du discours de politique
générale du premier ministre tout à
l'heure qui ne vous avais pas
complètement satisfaits en matière de
politique familiale est ce qu'il existe
aujourd'hui on peut le dire au sein du
parlementaire de singularité plutôt
porté sur la question familiale qui ne
serait pas du tout là en tout cas qui se
distinguerait de des autres élus de la
république en marche par exemple voilà
ça c'est important je pense aussi pour
leur parle beaucoup des valeurs
je sais que rafa elle adore les il a
raison l'ailier à la pratique et à faire
en sorte qu'il y en ait une culture
politique du centre dont on parle aussi
pour l'application autant que pour les
valeurs est-ce que vous dirai donc il y
a un positionnement en fait oui ça se
comprend bien la question alors déjà
pour répondre à votre question aussi
simplement que possible il faut regarder
un petit peu la composition puisque vous
parliez de 2e pilier de la majorité qui
est même le premier filet de la majorité
qui regroupe la république en marche
comme vous le savez il est composé
d'élus qui arrivent d'horizons très
divers
donc ils n'ont pas eux-mêmes sur le
sujet une ligne très arrêtées et ils
n'ont tellement pas de ligne arrêtée sur
le sujet que finalement ils ne se sont
pas non plus emparée de la question de
la de la famille il y a eu une tentative
si vous avez un peu suivi des travaux je
crois que c'était en 2018
une tentative de rapport sur la
politique familiale qui était portée il
y avait deux rapporteurs il y avait une
chiche pour la république en marche qui
n'est plus dans le groupe la république
en marche aujourd'hui inquiets partir
groupe
eds avec matthieu orphelin et il y avait
aussi gilles lurton un élu du groupe
l'est républicain
et ils n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre et
de ce fait ce rapport n'a pas pu être
présentés en commission des affaires
sociales et finalement il est resté
dormant et on en fera probablement rien
donc déjà il faut savoir qu
effectivement ici ne sont pas forcément
d'accord entre eux en interne sur 7 sur
ces questions là certains se disant
vraiment très très réformiste d'autres
un peu plus traditionalistes et donc il
n'y a pas forcément d'accord entre eux
et nous parce que et d'ailleurs vous
l'avez très bien rappelé c'est aussi
dans notre histoire il ya c'est donc
très naturellement finalement que nous
sommes arrivés sur la question et que
nous l'avons portée vous parliez
vous avez parlé d'un ministère de la
famille
j'ai bien compris que le premier
ministre a de tutelle n'est pas
centriste mais je si j'ai bien compris
vous avez dit aussi que celles et ceux
qui l'emportait et lé député centriste
voilà et c'est quelque chose que nous
souhaitons rue aujourd'hui typiquement
voir arriver de façon très claire
aujourd'hui la question de la famille
dans le gouvernement tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui elle est portée entre autres
sujets par une secrétaire d'état
rattaché au ministère des solidarités et
de la santé mais qui traite beaucoup de
la pauvreté même du plan pour voter
massivement et des questions de la
famille et encore une fois on est sur
des sujets comme les crèches les
assistantes maternelles
donc en fait on n'est pas dans le sujet
et nous souhaitons qu'il y ait
véritablement alors appelé je sais pas
trop comment mais en tout cas un
ministère de la famille d'accord alors
oui mais merci d'abord tout d'abord de
vos présentations respectives qui était
vraiment et passionnante extrêmement
riche
je fais court et direct
en dix ans le lieu depuis lequel je
parle donc je suis préoccupé r2 de
quatre enfants
entre 13 et 3 ans donc c'est ma
principale
mon principal point de vue sur la
question
je pense en fait sur cette question
politique à mieux il ya un enjeu
symbolique - presque de reconnaissance
dans le sens où je suis tout à fait
conscient notamment pour avoir vécu aux
états unis de toute la chance qu'on a de
vivre en france quand on voit des
enfants notamment prise en charge la
scolarité de la france reste un pays
privilégié par rapport à beaucoup
d'autres pays
enfin notamment des saisines sur ces
questions là mais je pense qu'il ya une
sorte de basculement un symbolique dans
le sens où avoir beaucoup d'enfants 6 et
enfin css mais je les intégrer à la
conséquence est presque culpabilisant
dans le sens où est-ce que c'est pas un
conséquent du point de vue
bad de du réchauffement climatique
c'étaient les propos de yves cochet sur
ces questions là donc chez ce qu'on crée
pas un fardeau pour la société des
dépenses publiques et donc peut-être
dans cet aspect là au sortir du
confinement ou comme les parents ont eu
à gérer le travail plus des enfants vous
allez peut-être en entendre d'ici mon
intervention parce que on a deux qui
sont pas retournés à l'école question de
reconnaissance c'est à dire ben
finalement en quoi avoir des enfants
aujourd'hui à bord famille c'est quelque
chose qui peut être utile socialement et
de ce point de vue la ccsn parole
publique c'est des petits symboles
finalement qui font équipe ou pas grand
chose mais qui peut-être peuvent tisser
du lien
la deuxième question c'est enfin on
remarque c'est autour des seuils parce
que les directement concernés par cette
question
points sont encore aux allocations
familiales plane mais en fait c'est un
obstacle concret je ne sais pas si ça a
pu être mesurée par des économistes
en termes de reprise de temps complet ou
de temps passé parce que dans la mesure
où l'allocation familiale qu'on touche
n'est pas fiscalisée
enfin il le delta le moment en fait si
on augmente nos ressources pour
retrouver un niveau de vie équivalent
sans allocation fait il faut vraiment
gagner beaucoup plus d'argent pour après
impôts avoir un niveau de ressources
équivalent à celui qu'on a juste quand
on est juste en dessous du seuil
puisqu'il ya non seulement en fait à
lallaing position marginale sur la
ressource gagner qui sera supérieure à
celle de qu'ils avaient sur les
allocations qu'il n'y avait pas de
l'imposition sur l'indication qu'il ya
aussi la taxe d'habitation par exemple
qui 2011 rend plus à payer
donc en fait je ne sais pas s'il ya pas
une sorte de trappe pour les gens en
fait qui passent des 20% enfin dans les
20% plus favorisés qui fait qu'il ya un
site internet qui peut avoir un impact
négatif sur l'égalité hommes femmes
c'est concrètement ma femme en fait
et 50 % et passe à 70%
mais on n'est pas sûr que le passage de
50 à 70 sous à temps complet va vraiment
nous à mieux enfin augmenter notre
niveau de jeu on pense plutôt c'est
peut-être de l'imaginaire et c'est pour
ça que je pense ce serait vraiment
intéressant qui a une étude économique
sur cet aspect là mais qui ça va plutôt
dix minutes temps disponible pour les
enfants et diminue aussi nos ressources
donc ça peut être contradictoire avec
l'objectif égalité homme-femme dans le
sens que ça peut être un frein pour
l'emploi féminin s'est concrètement
enfin notre copie n'est pas exemplaire
de ce point de vue là mais pour des
raisons pratiques de différence revenu
en forme c'est souvent les femmes qui se
mettent à temps partiel parce que c'est
moins douloureux
du point de vue des finances globales et
donc je ne sais pas si en fait pour
avoir des chances d'être entendu ce
serait pas intéressant d'avoir des
études précises sur tu ces seuils ses
effets de seuil est ce que finalement
ils sont pas contre-productif
du point de vue de la de la richesse
nationale si on regarde les choses d'un
point de vue macroéconomique et enfin le
dernier point c'était sur la question
corrélative des familles qui a su
d'isolement de toutes les personnes qui
vivent dans des situations d'isolement
nom choisi par rapport aux solidarités
que peuvent provoquer le fait d'être en
famille comment est-ce que effectivement
qu'il soit pour le grand âge ou pour les
personnes sensibles ont choisi peut y
avoir davantage de possibilités de
sociabilité des caisses quelles pistes
en fait pour permettre le maintien à
domicile ou la l'hébergement dans la
famille des personnes en situation de
dépendance en alternative aux epode
enfin voila c'était la troisième aux
interrogations que je m'étais encore
merci pour tes gars votre présentation
merci alors je vais essayer de vous
répondre et puis si je suis à côté vous
nous ramenez un peu dans le sujet alors
je vais vous faire une confidence de
quatre enfants brucy et je m'occupe je
me culpabilise pas du tout et je au
contraire pour moi les enfants sont une
richesse et c'est comme ça qu'il faut
la bordée c'est vrai qu'on a souvent un
raisonnement si je reviens petit peu au
rapport et notamment aux dernières
remarques ou réflexion que j'ai pu
entendre puisque j'ai travaillé
évidemment avec les administrateurs de
l'assemblée j'ai fait chiffrer aussi les
mesures que je porte
voilà qu'est ce que ça coûterait de
restaurer universalité qu'est ce que ça
coûterait de revenir au rabot équation
familiale donc j'ai laissé assez clair
sur le sujet et c'est vrai pour les
zones très souvent en termes de coût
mais il faudrait peut-être aussi inversé
notre regardez regardez ça plutôt sous
le prisme des bénéfices que cela peut
apporter notamment la richesse déjà
personnelle d'avoir des enfants
et puis aussi parce que ses enfants
demain ce sont des consommateurs etc etc
il faut aussi regarder je pense le verre
plutôt à moitié plein qu'à moitié à
moitié vide alors sur la question des
seuils je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous alors j'ai essayé d'obtenir
moi aussi ces éléments de réponse parce
que nous avons auditionné pas mal
d'économistes et je pense qu'il faudrait
que pour le coup aussi il faudrait qu'il
y ait une étude ou vraiment faite autour
de cette cette question là et d'ailleurs
c'est une question que je me pose
puisque par exemple dans le groupe qui
nous sommes tous favorables
évidemment au retour de l'universalité
certains d'entre nous disent mais alors
dans ce cas aujourd'hui donc je le
rappelle c'est conditionnel c'est
conditionné aux ressources et si on le
ramenait donc tels que c'était à
l'origine c'est à dire vraiment à
l'universalité certains dans le groupe
10 il faudrait peut-être fiscalisés
voyez est donc à nouveau moi j'ai peur
que finalement créé un effet de bord
quelque part et qu'on soit contre
productif en fait tu es complètement
peut-être même en opposition avec
l'objectif recherché initialement donc
enfin il ya quelque chose que je ne vous
ai pas préciser tout à l'heure mais
puisque vous avez parlé des allocations
et vous avez aussi parlé de l'isolément
alors j'ai bien entendu plutôt grant âge
etc
mais on a aussi la question quand je le
disais tout à l'heure des familles
monoparentales et donc dans ce rapport
je fais une proposition donc que vous
gardez pour vous à ce stade de
versements de d allocation dès le
premier enfant
voilà qui est aussi une façon de
justement lutter contre la précarité et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a mis
beaucoup de familles monoparentales et
donc c'est aussi une façon de les
accompagner alors sur l' isolement alors
pour avoir travaillé moi sûr je disais
tout à l'heure sur la question des
aidants et notamment des aidants
familiaux
il n'y a pas de réponse pré établi
aujourd'hui en plus il ya vraiment on
est confronté a pour le coup une
question très très réelle et sérieuse
qui est celle de l'inégalité
territoriale en région parisienne
il est peut être très très difficile
hébergé un grand-père une grand mère
parce qu'on n'a pas les logements qui
vont voilà et donc c'est la raison aussi
pour laquelle dans ce rapport la
question du logement est posé au centre
parce qu'il faut aujourd'hui aider les
familles à se loger dignement
alors évidemment je distingue le
dignement avec la possibilité réelle de
le faire en région parisienne où
globalement les logements sont plus
petit est souvent la seule réponse le
seul recours en effet c'est les fans
mais moi je crois et parce que encore
une fois je veux vraiment qu'on embrasse
la famille à tous les âges de la vie que
dès lors que c'est possible il faut
encourager
non pas le l'installation de l'aîné et
en ehpad mais si c'est possible bien de
pouvoir le garder avec soi même à la
maison
ça permet de lutter contre l' isolement
res te ment comme vous l'avez souligné
précédemment
est ce que j'ai oublié des choses à ce
que j'ai pris des notes comme ça très
rapidement sur vos différentes questions
non mais je me demande en fait si à
défaut d'une réponse d'économistes
prendre des études de cas en fait parce
que souvent fait c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus didactique la famille à machin est
en fête
est-ce que c'est pas ça pas un pouvoir
de conviction
c'était une autre question que j'avais
c'était quelles sont vos chances votre
quel est votre sentiment de pouvoir être
entendue et de pouvoir faire changer des
choses
ou est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
baroud d'honneur vous préparer les
choses sont lentes
vous avez des chances d'être alors
franchement je crois que je crois que
les esprits sont un peu mur
pour preuve il ya une peut-être un petit
peu anecdotique mais moi je le vois
l'évolution s'est il ya une démesure de
ce rapport que je porte depuis le départ
qui est une mesure de bon sens qui est
la restauration de la prime de naissance
avant la naissance voilà c'est tout bête
mais aujourd'hui la prime de naissance
n'est plus versée avant la naissance
mais elle est versée après la naissance
hors de bon sens on sait pour celles et
ceux qui ce tokyo et des enfants
notamment avec l'arrivée du premier
enfant
les dépenses et les investissements les
achats on les fait avant l'arrivée de
l'enfant en effet pas après et ça fait
trois ans que je me bats sur cette
question là où on n'est pas sur une
dépense puisque on est simplement sur la
première année un décalage de trésorerie
ce délire le verset après on verse un
tout petit peu avant et en plus ça
concerne vraiment les enfants qui sont à
cheval a qui sont nées fin décembre en
fait ça concerne pas grand monde et ça
fait trois ans que je porte cet
amendement et ça fait trois ans que j'ai
une fin de non recevoir et sous quelques
jours
un de mes collègues look et gilles
lurton d'ailleurs je vous en ai parlé
tout à l'heure que groupe l'est
républicain et qui avait travaillé
autour de ce rapport sur la politique
familiale avec le son collègue donc que
guillaume chiche deux groupes la reine a
déposé une ppl en ce sens
et sans vouloir dévoiler devant secret
les échos que j'ai sont ouverts et enfin
le gouvernement pourrait y être
favorables donc voilà il ya des signes
comme ça enfin il faut regarder aussi la
situation dans laquelle est notre pays
aujourd'hui après la crise on a cette
crise économique on va avoir cette crise
sociale on a cette crise de défiance on
à ce besoin fondamental de restaurer de
la cohésion sociale et donc je pense que
il ya davantage davantage l'oreille
enfin sur les mesures que nous avons
présentées
encore une fois c'est pas une
proposition de loi c'est un rapport ça
veut dire que nous amenons nous voulons
amener un certain nombre de sujets dans
le débat dans le débat public
et moi je le perçois et même je le
conçois très bien
compte tenu de tout ce qu'il se passe en
ce moment est de la dette abyssale qui
est la nôtre de porter ses propositions
en trajectoire
voilà en clair c'est une décision
politique c'est un choix politique c'est
une orientation politique
je souhaite que nous amenions ces
questions aux débats et j'entends que
l'on puisse les a menés par exemple que
ce soit sur l'universalité ou sur le
quotient familial
les a menées et les déployer dans le
temps mais autre petit signal quand même
à mon oreille si vous avez regardé un
petit peu la presse ces derniers temps
vous aurez constaté qu'un certain nombre
de ministres et bien commence à parler
ou à reparler de la famille en indiquant
peut-être qu'il faudrait aussi pourquoi
pas un ministère et la ce et auxquels je
pense ne sont pas forcément des
centristes
c'est donc un sujet aujourd'hui qu'il
est qui est au coeur et moi j'ai plutôt
j'ai plutôt bon espoir je n'imagine pas
que ce rapport soit rangé au placard
mais en tout cas je ferai tout pour que
vraiment ils soient menées dans le débat
et encore une fois quand nous avons
pensé ce rapport nous étions sur libé 2
d'une politique familiale ambitieuse et
comment aujourd'hui on allait répondre
aux enjeux aux défis de notre époque
mais je crois qu'on est plus jeune plus
là mais on est dedans d'une part et
d'autre part je vous le disais la crise
est passée par là et je souhaite aussi à
travers ce rapport porter des
propositions qui s'inscrivent dans le
plan de relance tout de suite et qui
soient des mesures très claires qui sont
des mesures très claires à destination
des familles tout à l'heure vous parlez
des familles qui ont été fragilisés par
la période par la crise et par la
période de confinement parce que
certains ont perdu leur emploi parce que
on voit d un recours massif est de plus
en plus important à l'aide alimentaire
par exemple et des familles qu'on ne
voyait pas arrivé précédemment
on a aussi une question qui est très
prégnante qui est celle du
malendettement ou de surendettement et
sur ces sujets là très précis moi
j'apporte des propositions et des
répondre donc on est et dans le plan de
relance et en même temps c'est un petit
peu le mot à la mode dans la proposition
d'une perspective pour rebâtir cette
politique qui peut être aussi considéré
véritablement comme un outil économique
voilà juste je voudrais faire un certain
nombre de remarques chez christophe me
permets sûr et qui sont enquis qui
rebondissent comme journaliste sur sauf
que pu dire le dessin et les ocz direct
pour convaincre
il ya trois registres possibles nous
convaincre 1 c'est l'orgie ça a été
évoqué c'est le registre là ce que jadis
les jésuites et d'autre de la
casuistique où c'est l'étude de cas
c'est le fait de passer par des cas en
général par des cas limites
c'est comme ça qu'on en fonction des
rebelles à est-ce que c'est ce que c'est
tolérable qu'un puis le deuxième c'est
de passer par des moyennes alors là ça
va être des études macroéconomiques mais
ça peut être aussi des études qu'on
pourrait appeler macro sociale
c'est-à-dire deux phénomènes d'exclusion
général puis à notre troisième point et
je crois que ça manque un petit peu et
c'est dommage parce que c'est aussi
l'objet d'un rapport justement lorsque
il n'est pas en phase de légiférer
c'est la théorie c'est à dire sur
quelles conceptions du monde on se fixe
et quand je dis théorie théorie je sais
que ça a été galvaudé mais c'est un mot
noble théorie ça veut dire perspective
téoria avoir une vision c'est ce que ça
veut dire aux grecs téoria c'est là que
le fait de voir exactement
et donc cette vision je pense qu'il est
intéressant aussi de savoir où elle se
trouve qu'elle est cette vision se veut
pas dire qu'on peut pas transiger
justement sur tout ce qui est autour
mais au moins quand on sait ce pourquoi
on ne transige pas ben c'est plus facile
de concilier sur tout le reste en fait
plutôt que d'être coup par coup et je
donne un exemple j'essaye d'être
j'essaye d'être justement précis 1
vous avez dit aujourd'hui on a le
sentiment qu'on peut avoir c'est à dire
un peu honte
lorsqu'on a quatre enfants sauf que moi
j'en ai cinq et j'ai pas honte du tout
et les effets de seuil
je connais très bien puisque mon épouse
et aux fonctionnaires moi aussi et en
gros c'est par passion qu'elle le fait
parce que si elle se mettait à mi temps
elle gagnerait par on verrait plus enfin
aujourd'hui compte tenu de l'impact réel
parce qu'on a fait un calcul
microéconomique a pour le coup est assez
précis qui n'est pas du tout fantasme
est clairement aux on aura un niveau de
vie supérieur si elle travaille et moi
entre guillemets oui il ya des petits
problèmes de ce point de vue là la
logique
la question aujourd'hui de la delà de la
famille de la place de l'individu la
place de la famille elle est directement
impactée par l'évolution des
perspectives sociales au sens des
théories de la vision sociale et vous
l'avez évoqué madame la députée enfin à
la fin de votre de votre intervention
originel parler de la famille comme
espace d'épanouissement et ça ça fait
partie de ce que les sociologues aux
grenadines gellar et d'autres appellent
le développement des valeurs poste
matérialiste de développement personnel
d'autonomie qui sont des valeurs qui
caractérisent ce qu'on appelle les
sociétés industrielles avancées voir les
sociétés postindustrielles nos sociétés
d'autres sociétés qui sont pas
développées par exemple en chine genre
aujourd'hui et ses valeurs elle se
développe même dans des sociétés qui
sont encore plus avancés que nous de ce
point de vue là par exemple les les
sociétés scandinaves
je pense à la suède la norvège et la
caisse de points se rend compte on se
rend compte que les gens de moins en
moins non seulement d'avoir des enfants
mais il y à un retour à la valorisation
de l'enfant mais sur un autre registre
pas celui des valeurs de sécurité des
valeurs industrielles le fait d'avoir
plus d'enfants pour des raisons ni les
valeurs traditionnelles ni les valeurs
industrielles mais encore autre chose
c'est-à-dire l'idée d'épanouissement d'
équilibre vous l'avez évoqué aussi
madame dans votre discours à un moment
donné dans vos réponses en disant oui
mais moi justement on n'évoque pas assez
là ce que ça peut enrichir d'avoir des
enfants
ça c'est typiquement un discours qui
aurait été inaudibles dans les années 50
moi te dire quasiment pas à vraiment
compréhensible aujourd'hui c'est
compréhensible
ce qui fait ça fait référence à quoi ça
même si on va plus loin si on parle de
la question de l'écosystème familia des
écosystèmes en général il ya une
écologie de la famille l'écologie une
vision écologique du monde
là on a des visions du monde qui
s'affrontent et pour le cours doit pas
avoir peur de se situer c'est là où là
le débat anthropologique à mon sens
c'est fondamental y compris pour la gpa
n'est pas ce que vous avez d'un côté une
vision qu'ont pour appeler qui est
appris d'ailleurs la deep ecology
l'écologie dit profonde et qui peut
considérer que l'humain est une sous mur
d'allemands de souvenirs du vivant et
que dans un certain écho écologistes
extrêmes vont aller jusqu'à dire vont
pas dans les discours politiques ils
vont pas jusque là mais certains des
idéologues peuvent aller jusque là en
disant il faut tellement si l'humain
disparaît c'est pas grave parce que ce
qui est important c'est le vivant en
tant que tel donc c'est une certaine
idée de la nature comme étant la nature
temps une sorte de nouvelle absolue sans
se rendre compte d'ailleurs que c'est
une nouvelle théologie qui peut devenir
tellement dogmatique qu'elle en est
totalitaire et puis on à l'écologie
humaniste l'écologie humaniste allait
centrer sur l'homme mais l'homme
respectueux de son environnement
deux des différentes formes d'existence
des différentes forme d'épanouissement
pour le essayer de limiter au maximum la
souffrance sociale est peut-être la
souffrance en général en l'étendant à
des règnes qu'on peut appeler les règnes
animal etc chaque fois en y
réfléchissant à partir de ce que nous
sommes
en pratique c'est à dire des humains et
donc cette perspective elle nous
interdit de mépriser les mains d'avoir
honte d'avoir des enfants etc
elle est une perspective particulière et
donc c'est pour ça que moi je crois que
une famille politique se doit à un
moment donné non seulement de réfléchir
en termes de cas en terme de moyenne
mais aussi en termes de perspectives et
on est dans un certain sens sa marque
c'est à dire que prône on parle beaucoup
j'entends beaucoup entendu parler dans
le mouvement centriste
les valeurs les valeurs ça parce que je
critique je le disais les valeurs les
valeurs les valeurs les valeurs bien
force de parler des valeurs moi
j'aimerais les voir précisément c'est à
dire j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait un
positionnement clair cohérent sur ses
valeurs et qu'on sache que c'est ça et
pas autre chose aussi
de ce point de vue là qui a un vrai
noyau il ya vraiment quelque chose
le patient le passé a montré raphaël que
justement tant sur le plan de
l'énonciation des valeurs ou l'énoncé
des valeurs que sur leur mise en
pratique le centrisme avait fait ses
preuves et le questionnement la société
très contemporaine aujourd'hui que
effectivement en fait on essaie de poser
des questions sur très contemporain mais
ça a été en tout cas sur les questions
de famille
bien démontré par les centristes mais je
laisse ma dame mais j'en suis d'accord
je suis d'accord et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que je m'engage ici mais oui
bien sûr et qu'est ce qui pousse dans
l'actualité du centrisme actuelle dans
sa sa recomposition nécessaire dans la
situation politique actuelle
alors je vous propose ma députée de si
vous voulez de répondre aux propos de
raphaël et puis on en mettra en ondes
devra malheureusement à arrêter là leur
d'audition puisqu'on a un schéma un
schéma horaire à créneaux horaires à
respecter et je vous laisse donc à
carros merci je rebondis effectivement
sur ce que vous avez appris la théorie
ou la vision j'ai compris finalement à
la fin de votre propos que vous parliez
au sens large
il est non pas uniquement sur le rapport
parce que j'allais vous dire que en tout
cas cette vision de cette perspective
elle existe bien dans les dents les
travaux que nous avons mené j'espère
vous avoir fait passer vraiment ce
message là y compris d'ailleurs se
fassent les mêmes l'intitulé est
l'intitulé de la mission est donc nous
essayons en tout cas j'essaie à mon
niveau
simplement de porter cette vision là
pour la famille dans nos sociétés
aujourd'hui et pour demain voilà pour
que ce soient parfaitement claires
merci bien à vous tous on voit bien
quand même que sur ce thème là et comme
sur d'autres d'ailleurs
il y avait vraiment une forme de
concordance des temps entre ce que nous
avons vécu et ce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui
même si naturellement dans l'action
contemporaine au jour le jour
aujourd'hui même je dirais on n'a pas
encore tous les résultats mais s'inscrit
bien un comportement peut-être député
depuis trois ans qui vous l'avez dit
prend la suite d'une tradition une
lignée qui équipe réserve et une
historienne spécialiste de la famille
avait dit que le xxième siècle la cites
le xxème siècle des familles sera
marquée par du sceau de la diversité et
c'est toute l'oeuvre en fait de la
législation de parvenir à dégager le
droit un droit clair sur cette diversité
des familles
et peut-être et là c'est la question qui
se pose si votre rapport sur la mission
d'information abouti un jour peut-être
rapidement à une proposition de loi ou à
la création d'un ministère de la famille
faire la preuve finalement qu' on aura
conservé cette tradition de très forte
présence est rentré sur la question de
la famille voilà en tout cas le sommes
très très contents et charles se
rappeler juste la référence de
l'hebdomadaire l'express à cet article
sur le rapport entre le climat et le
nombre d'enfants
il est dans la dans la partie
conservation la conversation pardon sur
auzolle on peut le retrouver
l'intérêt au fait de la narration qu'il
ya derrière ce ton par les rafales c'est
aussi qui emporte la langue c'est le
grand récit en fait et ça que quand
récit dominant à mon équipe en ce moment
en vain tel que je le perçois c'est les
gens qui décident de ne pas avoir
d'enfants pour sauver le climat parce
que l'avenir leur paraît trop incertain
et à mon avis il est culturellement
dominant et quel est le grand récit
alternatif qui peut être construit pour
dire mais non c'est pas contradictoire
de sauver le climat et mais c'est un
combat culturel c'est pas une idée pas
actuellement c'est plutôt cette idée là
quelqu'un qui est de moi mais je me
signe un verre de perception
merci charles merci raphaël merci madame
la députée donc la prochaine audition la
prochaine le prochain atelier solidarité
société aura lieu le 26 juin prochain
elle comme rapporteur et d'ici là ne
sont peut-être l'occasion enfin d'ici là
où après d'ailleurs de nous retrouver
pour d'autres d'autres conditions très
intéressantes comme celle ci
c'était passionnant c'est beaucoup merci
beaucoup merci à tous merci beaucoup
merci à tous les militants qui nous suit
ne suivront pas ce que c'est
c'est enregistré en interne et qui nous
suivront prochainement au revoir merci